en vídeos anteriores hablamos
extensamente sobre política fiscal y en
otros vídeos hablamos extensamente sobre
política monetaria pero ahora vamos a
hablar sobre las dos al mismo tiempo
porque en cualquier país puede haber
algún tipo de política fiscal y en
paralelo algún tipo de política
monetaria primero vamos a recordar qué
es una política fiscal sería cuando el
gobierno cambia la cantidad de los
impuestos o el gasto del gobierno
entonces esto es sobre impuestos y/o el
gasto del gobierno y porque es
importante bueno si cambiamos la
cantidad de impuestos estamos cambiando
la cantidad de dinero que los individuos
o las empresas tienen con lo que se
puede cambiar la demanda agregada del
mismo modo el gobierno cuando gasta más
o menos y eso también puede cambiar la
demanda agregada y eso se puede usar
como una herramienta para intentar
planificar la producción de la economía
ahora por otro lado la política
monetaria es muy importante que no se
confundan
2 la política monetaria se refiere a los
bancos centrales y sé que muchos de
ustedes estarán pensando hoy el banco
central no es parte del gobierno y yo
les diría que depende en qué país estén
y depende de cómo vean la parte
monetaria del gobierno por ejemplo en
eeuu el sistema de reserva federal es
casi independiente
es cierto que el ejecutivo hace
asignaciones incluyendo la del
presidente del banco de la reserva
federal pero debe actuar de forma
independiente del gobierno federal ahora
lo que se refiere a los bancos centrales
es el cambio en la oferta monetaria
oferta monetaria que muchas veces
impacta las tasas de interés
y ahora porque importaría esto si
estamos pensando en la planificación por
así decirlo en lo que respecta a la
producción con pleno empleo bueno con
las tasas de interés bajas los préstamos
son baratos entonces la gente puede
desear pedir prestado para gastar más o
las empresas pueden desear pedir
prestado para invertir más por otro lado
si tenemos tasas de interés altas
sucedería lo contrario de cualquier
forma tendrá un impacto en la demanda
agregada con ese antecedente veamos dos
escenarios para una economía
llamemos a este primer escenario
escenario 1 pausa en el vídeo y piensa
en cómo está operando esta economía en
relación con el pleno empleo
bueno aquí podemos ver que el nivel de
equilibrio de la producción
-jesús 1 está por debajo de la
producción con pleno empleo entonces
aquí tenemos una brecha negativa de la
producción y desde el punto de vista del
gobierno federal
probablemente digan vamos a hacer una
política fiscal expansiva para mover la
curva de demanda agregada hacia la
derecha que sería una política fiscal
expansiva bueno podríamos bajar los
impuestos esto podría mover la curva de
demanda agregada hacia la derecha porque
la gente tendría más dinero en sus
bolsillos las empresas tendrían más
dinero para gastar y para invertir la
otra opción es que el gobierno gaste más
directamente si el gobierno gasta más
eso también moverá la curva de la
demanda agregada hacia la derecha pero
en paralelo con la política fiscal como
se vería la política
monetaria bueno una política monetaria
expansiva sería el incremento de la
oferta monetaria incremento de la oferta
monetaria con el objetivo de tener un
impacto o generalmente debería tener el
impacto de bajar las tasas de interés lo
que haría que el endeudamiento fuera más
barato y así las empresas podrían
invertir más y la gente podría pedir
prestado y gastar más si estas dos cosas
suceden vamos a mover la demanda
agregada hacia la derecha de modo que
con esta política fiscal y esta política
monetaria expansivas podríamos llegar a
tener una situación como ésta tal vez la
demanda agregada se mueva lo suficiente
como para tener un mundo como éste
entonces esta sería la curva de demanda
agregada 2 ahora nuestro nivel de
producción de equilibrio es igual a la
producción con pleno empleo y nuestro
nivel de precios ha aumentado y
generalmente hablando ya sea que
hablemos de una política fiscal
expansiva o una política monetaria
expansiva
vamos a ver que el nivel de precios va a
aumentar ahora vamos a ver el escenario
2 a qué nos enfrentamos aquí bueno como
pueden imaginar es la situación opuesta
tenemos una brecha de producción
positiva o inflacionaria nuestro nivel
de producción de equilibrio está por
encima de la producción con pleno empleo
esta es una situación en la que el
gobierno federal probablemente diría
nuestra economía está en riesgo de un
sobrecalentamiento esto no es lo que
dirían típicamente esto les gusta porque
es bueno para ganar elecciones pero si
el gobierno es un gobierno prudente
probablemente diga que es tiempo de
pagar algo de la deuda externa del
gobierno o ser un poco más responsable
fiscalmente así que lo que probablemente
harán sea tener una política fiscal
contractiva lo que sería incrementar los
impuestos
o disminuir el gasto del gobierno
ninguna de estas cosas es muy popular en
general una política fiscal contractiva
no es una buena forma de ganar
elecciones pero un gobierno prudente
podría estar dispuesto a hacer
cualquiera de estas cosas por las mismas
razones que acabamos de decir podría
tener el efecto de desplazar la demanda
agregada hacia la izquierda del mismo
modo la reserva federal probablemente
quiera hacer una política monetaria
contractiva y una política monetaria
contractiva es más común la reserva
federal dice cuando producimos por
encima de nuestra producción con pleno
empleo la inflación podría salirse de
control entonces lo que podrían hacer es
reducir la oferta monetaria la oferta
monetaria lo que tendría el impacto o
generalmente tendría el impacto de
aumentar las tasas de interés haciendo
que el endeudamiento sea más costoso
para que las personas no puedan pedir
prestado y así gastar menos y las
empresas puedan invertir menos
en cualquiera de las dos políticas
tendremos el efecto de mover la demanda
agregada hacia la izquierda la demanda
agregada se verá así esta es la demanda
agregada 2 nuestro nivel de producción
de equilibrio está en la producción con
pleno empleo y ahora nuestro nivel de
precios ha disminuido en términos
generales la política monetaria
contractiva y/o la política fiscal
contractiva tendrán el impacto de al
menos frenar la inflación aquí lo vamos
a dejar la gran conclusión es que la
política fiscal y la política monetaria
rara vez actúan aisladamente a menudo
cuando estamos en una brecha de
producción negativa tenemos políticas
expansivas en ambas dimensiones y en una
brecha de producción positiva podría ser
prudente tener políticas contractivas en
ambas dimensiones ahora una pregunta que
podríamos hacernos es qué pasa si van en
direcciones opuestas
qué pasa si por ejemplo la política
fiscal es expansiva mientras que la
política monetaria
es contractiva bueno ahí depende podrían
compensarse entre sí de hecho a veces el
banco central puede tener una política
contractiva porque piensa que el
gobierno federal está siendo demasiado
expansivo todas son cosas interesantes
en las que podemos pensar hasta el
próximo vídeo